je pense personnellement que chaque fois
qu'il est possible de faire appel aux
administrations françaises
c'est bien sûr plus favorable pas
seulement pour les raisons d'économie
que vous citez puisqu'il ya pas besoin
de débourser l'argent supplémentaire
mais aussi parce que l'administration
française est d'une très grande qualité
et donc lui faire confiance c'est en
plus important de la part d'ea et des
responsables et c'est la garantie
souvent d'avoir des travaux de qualité
il s'avère que sur certains points
particuliers soit il n'y a pas dans les
administrations puisque le monde moderne
est devenu complexe il n'y a pas
forcément sur un point ou sur un autre
d'une compétence soit qu'il y a besoin
d'une coordination entre diverses
administrations parce que la seule
limite de notre administration c'est que
parfois du fait d'une habitude un peu
bureaucratique elle fonctionne en silo
et donc de temps en temps il ya besoin
sur des aspects particuliers de chef
d'orchestre qui puisse faire fonctionner
les divers administration qui peuvent
être impliqués pour tel ou tel domaine
dans la fonction publique beaucoup de
services ont été réduits donc là
expertise qui existait a commencé à
diminuer
et c'est pour ces raisons là que aussi
bien les chevaux national qu'à l'échelon
même local des collectivités locales
conseil municipal ils ont fait appel à
des cabinets sur des dossiers très
différent que ce soit la santé que ce
soit la gestion des services publics
d'eau d'été cher tout un tas de choses
comme ça parce que on n'y a qu'une en
face de nous dans la fonction publique
une expertise et une rapidité répondre à
des questions qui nous impact au niveau
des élus et alors
pourquoi je vais demander ce cabinet
parce que je m'étais rendu compte que
oui il y avait des cabinets américains
mais pas seulement
simplement ce que je m'étais rendu
compte c'est que leur indépendance poser
problème c'est qu'ils n'étaient pas si
indépendant que ça et ensuite
effectivement on a fait appel être de
plus en plus à ces cabinets et c'était
de plus en plus cher tous ces éléments
là où mis bout-à-bout font que oui
aujourd'hui on est obligé de faire appel
à ce cabinet mais que tant qu'il n'y a
pas dans la fonction publique de manière
indépendante des cabinets qui pourrait
répondre justement à la demande de
l'état des régions des départements et
les collectivités locales
eh ben on va avoir un problème de plus
en plus importante parce que sa grève
les budgets
et puis je vous dis la dépendance
l'objectivité n'y est pas forcément je
pense que dans l'immédiat il n'y a pas
de véritable danger mais il ne faut pas
non plus sous-estimer la menace pour
l'avenir si cela se développer cet appel
au cabinet privé d'autres pays cela de
se développer d'une façon absolument
systématique dans de nombreux domaines
en effet il est toujours difficile au
moment où ils sont sollicités de
connaître absolument tous les liens
d'intérêts qu'ils peuvent avoir et en
multipliant ce recours à ces cabinets
privés
effectivement on se mettrait parfois en
péril
je crois qu'il vaut quand même beaucoup
mieux garder les liens habituel quand
vous êtes dans le secteur public les
liens du secteur public doivent être
maintenus le plus possible et donc je
crois que nous devrons appelée de nos
voeux
le fait qu'il y ait à l'avenir des
justifications qu'ils soient chaque fois
donné lorsqu'on recours à un cabinet
privé
pourquoi en définitive le nombre de ces
sollicitations reste raisonnable et ne
crée pas la menace que vous avez évoqué
de nous mettre en position de dépendance
vis-à-vis d'intérêts commerciaux ou
nationaux d'autres pays et je crois que
la wii il nous faut être vigilant pour
garder
notre souveraineté est intacte depuis
une dizaine d'années on voit cette
évolution grandir serre et donc une
sorte de lobbying on appartient aux
yvelines des entreprises mais c'est
aussi quelque part de nos vies mais ça
montre aussi que les élus ont peut-être
besoin de formation il ya des budgets de
formation il ya peu d'élus qui vont en
formation et comment besoin parce
qu'effectivement ça devient de plus en
plus complexes il y avait beaucoup
direct et via pauvre réglementation qui
évolue donc effectivement c'est très
compliqué on peut se faire entourer de
personnes de la fonction publique
territoriale
mais c'est difficile de trouver des
personnes comme ça qu'ils peuvent
remplacer la compétence et la rapidité
de ses cabinets extérieurs donc oui
c'est un danger qui va devenir de plus
en plus important parce que c'est vrai
que quelque part c'est eux qui vont
impulser certaines orientations souvent
partagés quand même par les principaux
élus mais la plupart des élus dans les
conseils municipaux les conseils
départementaux et joe nocera
je pense que la compétence je pense
qu'elle diminue donc on a besoin de
sécurité et donc on fait appel
ces cabinets qui de mon point de vue
risque de prendre trop d'importance